do you have any of the following
symptoms that are unusual for you
cough shortness of breath short sore
throat chills congestion or runny nose
no all right do you have diarrhea or
nausea vomiting
no hey do you have a female yeah in
front of all these people
i know
now everybody that comes out here isn't
going to get this young lady to do the
vaccination because you have to have a
day off but
yes i don't
i'm not afraid of needles i'm not afraid
of you
thank you this is my full pharmacy
friend a full pharmaceutical school of
pharmacy
school of pharmacy kids yeah
ready
okay it was totally pain-free
it was a very simple procedure and i
encourage
everyone i beseech everyone please
please if you're eligible
down to the vaccination site please get
it make an appointment
and show up for your appointment it's
going to make a difference there's a
light at the end of this dark tunnel
that we've been going through we're a
lot closer to the end
of this pandemic than we are at the
beginning and these vaccines are what's
going to make the difference
so i encourage everybody out there if
you're eligible or when you become
eligible
to get your vaccine please do it as soon
as you possibly can and
all through the vaccines are terrific
and i encourage you just to get whatever
one's available